central Sand Martins is one of the
world's most renowned fashion and design
schools every year the graduates display
their final collections at a
much-anticipated show Stefan's Eagle is
here to scout out up-and-coming talent
he's looking for raw gems yep understand
Matheson Martin's is well known for
being conceptual we try to find young
designers here who will take their work
to the next level and be provocative the
school's famous for that as well that
business without become the lucky ones
end up here at seagulls fashion portal
not just a label 13,000 designers from
around the world have been featured here
over the past five years the best of
them get a retail forum in the sites
online shop the industry is taking
notice let's target young designers at
mizzou young designers are the new trend
so to speak was all yet a big plot to
shore so everyone wants to work with
them it starts with the big companies
they all want to do a young designer
project and all the big labels have a
young designer award it's often we
co-sponsored these awards my sins can be
a hint of these awards the team works
closely with leading international
fashion schools when not just a label
broadcasts the Florence based Polly moda
school show more than five thousand
viewers tuned in to watch the event live
heads count Robert Cavell Clark notes
down the most promising talents
when we say we look for some two things
like quality and creativity so things
the difference I mean it's new and and
yelling for grad shows I mean you can
see quite quickly i mean the certain
schools have different styles and
different aesthetics so ones like this
either quality is really high so i mean
all of them are really good the talent
scouts were particularly impressed with
this man James Kern's makes leather
shoes in his London studio but he never
went to a fashion school instead he
taught himself how to do it now he sells
his designs at burn not just a label
online shop a pair goes for about four
hundred and fifty euros
James's lubavitch bill james is a great
example of a new direction in fashion
design creates luxury items that are
completely different and for guns on
their homemade pieces and obviously not
as affordable as the sneakers you can
get on the high street is dima flaked
off of but it's a new concept and i
think he's really innovate 120 club de
sericea say annuity for high gear do
first effing and Robert regular visits
to their designers workshops are all
part of the job Swedish designer Fanny's
gavel was one of the first to be
featured on not just a label five years
ago since then her career has taken off
her jewelry has been ordered by
superstars like Rihanna and lady gaga
rihanna I was working on her world tour
and I ended up working is her assistant
creative director and the first time I
met her she worked on set and she
pointed at me and she's like yes this is
what I want for my video tomorrow stars
like Rihanna are always on the lookout
for something different for a more
individual look celebrities are
increasingly calling on independent
designers
it's not look soo is it still about
luxury or do I want to wear something no
one else has I think individuality or
luxury has changed so young designers
are great because there are only one or
two of their pieces out there i model
the stars know that and now so do many
consumers is the selfie to councilman
for budding talents not just a label
offers the chance to present their
designs to a wider audience and the
opportunity to be discovered and make
contacts in the fashion world we don't
really know how to like apply or how to
create our own label I really feel that
it could really be a platform forward to
get involved with the fashion label
whenever you have people interested in
your work you get inspired to create
more so i think that is definitely
something that's you know pushing along
the lines of going that direction more
than half a million people check out
Stephan and Roberts discoveries every
month not just a label has become an
influential platform showcasing
tomorrow's designers today